this is Norwegian driver rule a
Christian roost M now if he offers you a
lift
say no he's a master driving up almost
vertical cliffs it looks like it should
be impossible
this is extreme driving so why isn't the
car flipping backwards off the cliff now
things flip when center of gravity goes
beyond the pivot point so if you take my
arm here is the vehicle and this is one
tire here and this is the other tire
here if the centre of gravity is quite
high if it's up here
you can see if it goes past the first
tire it's gonna flip all the way because
the sentient gravity is gone beyond that
pivot point and that's incredibly
important a low center of gravity is key
okay so they have a low center of
gravity but what else is special about
these cars to maximize the friction you
need big tires with big treads and as
much surface area as possible
the tires are also going to be partially
deflated which means you'll get a large
surface area so that they can grip into
the surface of the cliff
and listen to that sound
what's going on under the hood we need a
really powerful motor that can operate
in a low gear without stalling because
halfway up a mountain that is the last
thing you need so it's all about
friction center of gravity and power but
don't try this unless you have a special
clip climbing car
[Music]